[Music]
all right as we continue our exclusive
interview with the attorney general of
the united states uh attorney general
bar mr
attorney general um president commented
uh you were very clear by the way you
let me first say you had the patience of
job on steroids and human growth hormone
when you went before that clown show in
congress
god bless you for it because i don't
think i have the patience you do and
it was really pretty despicable to me
the president weighed in on dorm you
were very clear in your testimony
president doesn't tell you what to do
you're independent um president said
today that he hopes that the dorm report
and
and that you as attorney general won't
be politically
correct um i hope that too
mr attorney general i spent three years
on peeling the layers of an onion
in terms of premeditated fraud on the
fisa court
you have deleted subpoenaed emails you
have
a knowledge we know that they were
warned in august of 2016 not to trust
that
dossier which was the bulk of
information for the fisa warrants
the sub source in january 2017
confirms none of that was true it was
bar talk
i guess just as the wheels of justice
turn slowly
uh i feel impatience over it can you
give us any update
uh yes sean well first you know as to
the
as the political correctness if i was
worried about being politically correct
i wouldn't have joined this
administration
uh as i mentioned that's actually a good
line too okay yeah well
as i make clear i'm gonna call him as i
see him and that's why i came in i
thought i'm gonna i think i'm in a
position to do that
there are two different things going on
sean one i've said
that the american people need to know
what actually happened we need to get
the story of what happened in 2016 and
17 now
out that will be done the second
aspect of this is if people cross the
line if people involved in that activity
violated the criminal law
they will be charged and and uh
john durham uh is an independent man
highly experienced and his investigation
is pursuing a pace there was some delay
because of kovid
but i'm satisfied with the progress and
i've said there are going to be
development significant developments
before
the election but we're not doing this on
the election schedule we're aware of the
election
we're not going to do anything uh
inappropriate
before the election but we're not being
dictated to by this schedule what's
dictating the timing of this or
developments in the case
and there will be developments is
tomorrow uh there will be a development
in the case it
uh you know it's not earth-shattering
development but it is an
indication that things are moving along
uh at the proper pace as dictated by
uh the the facts in this investigation
mr attorney general you once said this
isn't about a report this is a criminal
investigation
um you were very clear that they spied
the
president of the united states was spied
on deep into his presidency you said
um now based on what we know
and andrew mccabe said it and sally
yates said it and rod rosenstein and
and sally yates would not sign those
warrants today
we know that they the fbi knew
beyond any doubt that it not only was
that dossier without the dossier yates
and mckay both say
there's no fisa warrant that they knew
it was false
they were told it was false law even
requires them as soon as they know that
it was false to go back to the fisa
court
based on what we know on the record
i just see premeditated fraud against
the court and i wouldn't even lie before
judge judy mr attorney general because i
think they'd throw away the key in my
case
well when we feel we can prove a crime
beyond a reasonable doubt it will be
charged
i can tell you that yeah let me ask you
about mail-in voting i
i paid very close attention again to
your interview with mark
uh and the those that want to experiment
with different ways of voting
they want to do this now with 82 days to
go before the election
i don't have confidence in government to
fulfill many promises at all
doesn't it lend itself to great
opportunity for fraud
yes i think it's it is grossly
irresponsible
to be doing what the democratic party is
doing now
we've had very close races in recent
history the country is
divided if anything we should be
assuring the integrity
of our elections so that government
going forward will be legitimate and
will be accepted as legitimate
the idea of conducting uh elections by
wholesale mail-in ballots
is reckless and wrong uh
everyone knows what has happened in
these cases we're not talking about
voters going requesting a barrett ballot
specifically
saying who they are proving who they are
and then submitting a ballot by mail
we're talking about
mail outs to everyone on the voting list
and every experience with
with that has had thousands and
thousands of ballots floating around not
just the state but the country
i have friends who haven't lived in
california in 21 years who receive
ballots uh there are ballots left in
boxes and apartment buildings
uh ballots are for for uh
people who used to live at addresses or
delivered to those addresses they can be
filled out by anybody
this is reckless and it and it could
create
uh uh serious questions about the
integrity of the election
and to do this uh when when there are a
closely divided country as we are
uh is playing with fire in my view
mr attorney general you talked about the
seattle police chief carmen best
i i felt wow what an amazing
what an amazing example of service and
dedication to her community
and how they she literally had to resign
because of this defund effort and
that she was not given the ability to
use the training
that that all police officers have we
know how to disperse crowds
it's usually tear gas it's usually
pepper spray involved but they've taken
these tools away from
officers i believe it's now created a
very dangerous situation for all of them
um i don't think it takes a lot of
mit or a harvard degree to figure out
this is not going to end well for a lot
of these cities
what do you say to those that are
demonizing the police these groups
you've talked about the group black
lives matter you talked about the group
and tifo or antapha and
and those that believe in joe biden i
won't bring you into politics but said
you know they've become the enemy
uh kamala harris says she's happy with
the lapd
defunding the police i don't think this
is going to end well
sir i think lives will be lost as a
result
well lives are being lost in violent
crime
and the demonization of the police you
know
carmen best is an example of the highly
competent and professional and dedicated
police professionals we have in this
country we're blessed with that
throughout the country
they're excellent and she is a great
example of it
and we should be supporting them and
being a police officer
is one of the it is the hardest job in
the united states we're asking people to
go into very dangerous situations
to have jobs that are terribly wearing
on them as individuals and on their
families
to go into potentially deadly situations
not knowing what will happen
and we have to continue to attract the
best people into these jobs
and unless we support the police we're
not going to have a police force
these communities are not going to have
the safety
now a lot of the liberals will buy
themselves out of that
they'll go you know to resort towns and
so forth and
they'll escape the consequences of it
but the people in the inner cities won't
their lives will be destroyed their
their opportunity
uh will be will you know they won't have
the opportunity they otherwise would
have their schools will be overrun by
gangs that's not caring about black
lives
and and people talk about implicit
racism or systemic racism
the racism in this country look no
further than our public education
system that's a racist system maintained
by the democratic party and
and the teachers union keeping inner
city kids
in failing schools instead of putting
the resources in the hands of the
parents
to choose the schools to send their kids
to
that's empowering kids that's giving
them a future
every child there are our nation's
national treasure
last question you did talk about the
political environment an
environment where people have been
trying to impeach donald trump from day
one we've now seen
the criminalization of political
differences
for example the the ig made referrals
about lying
about top officials in the fbi and
nothing happens there was no pre-dawn
raids
with 29 guys in tactical gear and
frogmen over
those process crimes uh nor were there
cnn cameras because those guys haven't
been arrested
i worry that america is descending into
a two-tiered justice system
am i wrong no i think it's the right
worry and it's the reason i came back
into government we can't let it happen
but here here's the thing sean the way
out of this
the way out of the politicization and
the corruption of the justice system
where it's used as a political weapon by
one party against another
is not to deliver tit for tat it's not
to use the tactics of the other side
it's to pull the rule of law use the
right standard
and that's what i'm trying to do one
standard
for everybody i know you can't share a
lot
i i spent three and a half years i think
we've found a lot of truth
about the one percent i always make the
distinction not the 99 percent of good
the premier law enforcement intelligence
agencies in the world
and i hope those that abuse power more
corrupt or exposed thank you for
your time sir thank you sean